here's what is real the washington
football team whoa
with a quarterback who has now crossed
the threshold beyond
25 percent of the league he's up to team
number nine that's insane
ryan fitzpatrick on a one-year 10
million dollar deal reportedly with
incentives that would take it to 12 man
twice what he was making with the
dolphins which may tell us everything we
need to know about whether or not he's
the guy
he joins the depth chart with kyle allen
and taylor heinecke and he's clearly the
best guy walking through the door
and there's ryan fitzpatrick a long time
ago
and look at it i thought charlie
whitehurst had a hell of a
transformation during his time in the
nfl i mean
this guy's been around almost as long as
tom brady and he's been with
all these different teams most recently
the dolphins where he was the relief
pitcher a position that you ideally
wouldn't have on a football team
no baseball yes but you want your
quarterback to be able to finish the
game this isn't about needing to wrap
your arm
in ice this is hey we need a spark and
fitzpatrick brings it my only concern
about fitzpatrick when you go all in and
make him your guy
yeah inevitably inevitably fits magic
becomes fits tragic
and you start looking to see who else
you could put on the field
that happens everywhere he's the starter
it ha
you're right you know i guess you could
maybe look at miami
a little mike i don't know do you agree
did that happen in miami it might be the
first place where i went like okay it
didn't totally it didn't become if it's
tragic
it didn't but it wasn't great they knew
last year they knew last
year when to use him and when to get him
out right no
they did that was the key and and you
know hey 10 million dollars
you know washington that's position that
team right now i mean
i don't know what they're going to do
it's going to be interesting to see you
know they're sitting in no man's land
like we talked about last week as far as
the nfl drafts concerned with 20
i don't know if it's going to be
somebody will be there that you can just
say oh we're going to be able to play
him this year
his contract tells you that ooh you know
yeah it's really good backup money
yet you know if you do play it's ok
it's pretty good money there and we're
going to let you earn more
so it makes sense from all angles one it
makes sense for ryan fitzpatrick yeah
you got a chance to maybe be the starter
once again
and then for washington you know again
mike that's one of those teams when we
hit the nfc east a few weeks ago
the more you kind of dig into them you
just go man washington's close
it's not far away here now there's a lot
of good things to like about their
football team here and of course they
still have some
money to spend and and we'll see where
it all goes but makes sense for them and
i think it makes sense for ryan
fitzpatrick
here's here's what i like about this too
to the extent washington is plotting
to try to take a quarterback if there's
a guy they fall in love with who they
think may be there at 19. right
having fitzpatrick now makes it far less
glaring
as the picks start to go 13 14
15 16. if you're in the 20s or out of
round one and there's a guy you love
who's sliding toward 19.
yeah if it's just kyle allen and taylor
heineke you may as well have a billboard
outside of your facility saying hey
watch us take a quarterback at 19.
so somebody knows they got to get to 18
minimum to keep that from happening
now with fitzpatrick it's it's less
obvious that you got to get in front of
19. and
that would be the irony for fitzpatrick
for the second straight year here comes
a first round quarterback to marginalize
me
and relegate me eventually to the bench
once the rookie's ready
and possibly to become the relief
pitcher if the rookie struggles
but at least he's getting 10 million
this year
as as compensation for possibly being
jerked around
by a coaching staff that won't go all in
with him i'd love to see what happens if
they go all in just treat this year as
all in
it's ryan fitzpatrick let's ride it as
far as we can
and if he gets injured then we got
heineken we got allen but let's go all
in with fitzpatrick and see where he can
take us i mean this is a team that won
the division this is a team that like
you said they're not that far off
it was just one of those moves that once
it happened
it was like the clouds part yeah you're
like why didn't i sunshine
right and you're like this is awesome
yeah right no
it totally is and mike i think you kind
of you know
you're spot on it takes that pressure
away
you know yeah i you you can go into the
year and just go these are our
quarterbacks so what
you know we're going to play the same
way we did last year except
you know hopefully they'll get them a
few more weapons than than maybe alex
smith and
and kyle allen had you know we talked
about they need another receiver to go
opposite to terry mclaurin
you do that you got ryan fitzpatrick
who at this point of his career is
better than alex smith
and can make more plays with his arm and
do those type of things
i mean again i think that's on the table
to what you're saying
unless maybe the right quarterback falls
in their lap via the trade or
you know maybe like you're talking about
it pick 19 maybe it's one of those
things where
one of these quarterbacks is there to be
had maybe early in the second round and
they trade up there to get them
i don't know they got a lot of different
avenues now though but they're not like
pushing in the corner to what you're
saying here
there's options and they can also just
go hey we'll stand pat with what we got
we'll kind of see
and use 2021 to figure out our next move
for our quarterback for 2022 and so on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports